looking to Netflix and chill this
weekend we've got just the thing
catch all these killer films before they
leave the streaming platform or possibly
for good
each of these titles will be gone by
September 1st so time is of the essence
here Godspeed
the hangover redefined the comedy genre
when it stormed into theaters in 2009
starring Bradley Cooper at Helms Doug
Billings and Zach Galifianakis the film
follows four theoretically upstanding
young men as they descend upon Las Vegas
for a bachelor party but the night they
arrived these stand-up dudes get full
down drunk and wake up the next morning
with no recollection of the night before
what's worse the groom-to-be as
mysteriously gone missing I looked
everywhere
Jim casino front desk nobody's seen Doug
he's not here now it's a race against
time as everyone scrambles to retrace
their steps and find Doug before it's
fiance figures out what's going on and
we're in a big hurry to get back so we
got going throughout that quest they
encounter some intensely strange and
unsavory characters all while suffering
from the mother of all hangovers so if
you guys know if there's only the
hangover we'll be staggering away from
Netflix on September 1st it's a film
that reinvigorated the Batman property
after the critical and commercial
failure of 1997's Batman and Robin
released in 2005 Batman Begins stars
Christian Bale as Bruce Wayne a dark and
brooding gentleman who witnessed a
brutal murder of his parents as a child
Wayne eventually becomes a full-fledged
vigilante determined to wipe crime off
the streets of Gotham City operating
under the guise of Batman the Caped
Crusader battles a nefarious
psychiatrist dr. Jonathan crane
portrayed by Killian Murphy
psychopharmacology is my prime
I'm a strong advocate outside he was a
giant in a year only the mind could read
new power otherwise known as scarecrow
at this iconic body is hell-bent on
plunging the city into the depths of
chaos the question is will he succeed
find out before Batman Begins flies away
from Netflix on September 1st hey here's
an idea why not turn your evening into a
dark and disturbing double feature you
simply can't go wrong with the Dark
Knight a 2008 sequel to Batman Begins
this time Batman takes on one of his
most notorious rivals the Joker played
to perfection by the lates Heath Ledger
Jarius throughout the film the maniacal
madman commits countless crimes
undercutting Batman's status in Gotham
and plunging the city into complete and
utter darkness this time the question is
has Batman finally met his match it's
the perfect time to reacquaint yourself
with Ledger's iconic performance on
October 4th Todd Phillips Joker film
will give us a freaky new spin on the
Clown Prince of Crime portrayed by the
always captivating Joaquin Phoenix the
Dark Knight's will be sipping away from
Netflix on September 1st so you need
Todd the Demon Barber of Fleet Street is
probably one of Tim Burton's weirdest
and most wonderful movies and that's
saying a lot considering all the
outlandish oddities he's made in the
past a silver screen translation of
Stephen some time and who will this
musical of the same name Sweeney Todd
features Johnny Depp in the title role a
Barba / serial killer who cuts the hair
and throats of his customers with a
signature straight razor meanwhile
Todd's right-hand woman mrs. Nellie
Lovett portrayed by Burton's ex-wife and
frequent collaborator Helena Bonham
Carter uses his leftovers as the main
ingredients in a special meat pies or
don't you ban the boy then shoot him up
I wouldn't worry about him he's a simple
thing the film slashed its way to the
top of the box office at December 2007
earning 152 million dollars worldwide
against its 50 million dollar production
budget raking in dazzling reviews from
critics a National Board of Review
selected pick for the top 10 movies of
the year so we need sod also took home
numerous Golden Globe Awards and an
Academy Award for best art direction
Sweeney Todd leaves no flake
on September 1st so check it out now
before it's too late
chop-chop eager for more fast and
furious in your life after cutting the
franchise spin-off Hobbes ensure planet
back-to-back-to-back open session of
three Fast and Furious films that won't
be available to stream on Netflix for
much longer they're going going gone
baby where is he going
went to the carwash whatever go fetch my
car go fetch your car the first three
entries in the high octane series are
skidding away from Netflix on September
1st The Fast and the Furious 2 fast 2
furious
and The Fast and the Furious Tokyo Drift
if you're looking for a mindless
adrenaline rush you simply can't go
wrong with this franchise but you better
get a move on
adapted from Anthony Burgess's novel of
the same name Stanley Kubrick Starck
futuristic fantasy a Clockwork Orange
follows the exploits of a charismatic
young sociopath named Alex played with
insidious glee by Malcom McDowel jolly
good Alex and his merry band of thugs
commits ultraviolence rather they go
until alex has finally thrown into jail
following one of his intensely heinous
crimes in order to return to society he
agrees to undergo rehabilitation through
psychological conditioning and when he's
finally back on the streets it's Alex's
turn to be the victim or is it whether
revisiting the film or checking it out
for the first time you simply won't be
able to take your eyes off the screen
check out a Clockwork Orange before it
leaves Netflix on September 1st because
it would be a crime to miss it check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos but your
favorite films are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and to the bail
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]